450 pounds overweight to becoming an
extreme endurance athlete competing in
five Ironman triathlons in a row that's
a 2.4 miles of swimming 112 miles of
biking and a marathon that's 26.2 miles
long so we're talking 170 miles total
all that everyday back to back for 5
days straight so how did this once
overweight Club become a super fit stud
AHA Heim is so excited to bring in
ritual finding finding ultra is your
book and it is a fantastic book rich how
did you do it we all want to know thanks
for having me Jane's great to be here
how did I do it well it all began with
adopting a plant-based diet you know
really the journey begins and ends with
my new changing my nutrition like like
you said when I turned 40 I was 50
pounds overweight but more importantly I
just felt horrible you know my life had
been about career family kids and all
that sort of thing that good stuff but
in the interim you know I really didn't
I didn't tend to my health and I wasn't
watching what I ate and when I turned 40
I decided to make a change I adopted a
vegan diet and the energy the incredible
energy boost that I realized from doing
this sort of girded my resolve to return
to a fitness program and it began slowly
and grew from there but everything that
I've achieved as an athlete I really
believe begins and ends with
plant-based nutrition now I see you
putting a lot of stuff into a blender
and it's green stuff tell us about that
lots of greens I love my Vitamix blender
as you can see there yeah at least twice
a day I blend up drinks I love to make
all kinds of smoothies I like I love
kale I love spinach I like all kinds of
fruit and superfoods like chia seeds and
maca powder basically you know whatever
I have in my kitchen which is generally
fresh organic produce goes into that
thing and I'm drinking from it all the
time at briefly ten seconds it gives you
the energy you need absolutely no
question about it
it's fueled me through 25 our training
weeks for sure and and I love it
rich we love you